- [Instructor] The
thermodynamic favorability
of a chemical reaction
can be affected by the temperature.
Let's say we have a generic reaction
where the reactants
turn into the products.
As a quick review, when the
standard change in free energy,
delta G naught,
is less than zero,
the forward reaction is
thermodynamically favorable.
Therefore, the net
reaction goes to the right
to make more of the products.
And when delta G naught
is greater than zero,
the forward reaction is
thermodynamically unfavorable.
That means that the reverse
reaction is favorable
and the net reaction would go to the left
to make more of the reactants.
One way to calculate delta G naught
is to use the following equation.
Delta G naught is equal to delta H naught
minus the absolute temperature
times delta S naught.
And since delta H naught
is talking about the
standard change enthalpy,
for this equation
delta H naught will be
called the enthalpy term.
And because delta S naught
is talking about the
standard change in entropy,
the absolute temperature
times delta S naught
will be referred to as the entropy term.
So when we're trying to figure out
if delta G naught is negative
or if delta G naught is positive,
we need to consider the
sign for delta H naught,
the sign for delta S naught,
and sometimes we also need to consider
what the temperature is.
There are four possible
combinations of signs
for delta H naught and delta S naught
as we can see in this table.
For each of these four combinations,
we're gonna think about the temperatures
at which delta G naught is less than zero
and we're gonna finish
filling out this table.
To start with, we're gonna
think about the situation
where delta H naught is negative
and delta S naught is positive.
So for this first possible combination,
when delta H naught is negative,
we say that's an exothermic reaction.
And when delta S naught is positive,
that's saying there's
an increase in entropy
as reactants turn into products.
So let's think about the
sign for delta G naught
if we plug in some numbers
for delta H naught,
temperature, and delta S naught.
And when I plug in some numbers,
I'm not really concerned
about a particular reaction.
I'm not concerned about units.
I'm not concerned about
significant figures.
I'm just interested in
looking at the numbers
and seeing how the math affects
the sign for delta G naught.
So for delta H naught,
I'm saying that's -100.
For T, I'm saying that's 100,
and for delta S naught,
I'm saying that's +0.1.
So this would be equal to -100 - 10,
which is equal to -110.
So delta G naught is negative.
Notice how a negative entropy term
favors getting a negative
value for delta G naught.
And notice how a positive entropy term,
since we're subtracting
that in our equation
is also favorable for
getting a negative value
for delta G naught.
Also notice, no matter what
we put in for the temperature
since delta S naught is positive,
the entropy term will always be positive.
And since we're subtracting
it in our equation,
we would always get a negative
value for delta G naught.
So whenever delta H naught is negative
and when delta S naught is positive,
delta G naught will be negative
no matter what the temperature.
So if we go back to our chart
for our first possible combination,
when delta H naught is
negative, that's favorable.
And when delta S naught as
positive, that's also favorable.
Therefore delta G naught is
less than 0 at all temperatures.
So I'm gonna go ahead and write in here,
'at all temperatures' in our chart.
As an example of this,
let's consider the conversion
of ozone gas into oxygen gas.
Since energy is released,
this is an exothermic reaction,
and delta H naught is negative.
And since we're going from 2 moles of gas
on the reactant side
to 3 moles of gas on the product side,
that's an increase in entropy.
So delta S naught is positive.
Since delta H naught is negative
and delta S naught is positive,
delta G naught for this reaction
is less than zero at all temperatures.
That means the forward reaction
is thermodynamically favorable,
and ozone gas would turn into oxygen gas,
and this reaction would
occur at all temperatures.
The second possible
combination for the signs
is when delta H naught is positive
and when delta S naught is negative.
When delta H naught is positive,
that's an endothermic reaction.
And when delta S naught is negative,
there's a decrease in entropy
going from reactants to products.
Once again we're gonna
plug in some numbers
and solve for delta G naught.
So for delta H naught,
let's say that's +100,
for the temperature term,
let's say that's 100,
and delta S naught, let's say that's -0.1.
When we do the math,
we get positive 100 - negative 10,
which is equal to +110.
So delta G naught is positive.
Notice when the entropy term is positive,
that's not favorable for
getting a negative value
for delta G naught.
And when the entropy term is negative,
since we're subtracting this negative,
we would actually be
adding the entropy term.
And that would not favor
a negative value for delta G naught.
Also notice,
no matter what you put in
for the temperature here,
you're always gonna get a negative value
for the entropy term.
And if the enthalpy term is positive,
since we would mathematically
be adding the entropy term,
we would always get a positive
value for delta G naught.
So whenever delta H naught is positive
and delta S naught is negative,
delta G naught will be positive
no matter what the temperature.
So going back to our charge
when delta H naught is positive,
that was not favorable,
and when delta S naught was negative,
that was also not favorable.
So it doesn't matter
what the temperature is.
Delta G naught will not be less than zero.
Therefore, on our chart
here we can write in,
at no temperature will delta
G naught be less than zero.
As an example of this,
let's look at the reverse
of the reaction we saw
for the first possible combination.
Before we had ozone
turning into oxygen gas,
and now we have oxygen
gas turning into ozone.
Because heat is on the reactant side,
we know this reaction is endothermic
and delta H naught is positive.
And since we're going from 3 moles of gas
on the reactant side
to 2 moles of gas on the product side,
that's a decrease in entropy,
and delta S naught is negative.
Since delta H naught is positive
and delta S naught is negative,
delta G naught will
never be less than zero.
It doesn't matter what the temperature is.
And so the forward reaction
is always thermodynamically unfavorable.
The third possible combination of signs
has both delta H naught and delta S naught
as being negative.
Once again we're gonna plug
some numbers into the equation
and see what happens to
the sign of delta G naught.
So let's say delta H naught is -100.
The temperature is 100 and
delta S naught is -0.1.
Doing the math, we get
negative 100 minus negative 10.
So that's -100 + 10,
which is equal to -90.
Let's think about why
we got a negative value
for delta G naught.
The enthalpy term is negative,
which favors a negative
value for delta G naught.
The entropy term is also negative,
but since we're subtracting
the entropy term,
it actually gets added
for the overall delta
G naught calculation.
So the entropy term is not favorable.
However, in this case,
the favorable entropy term
outweighs the unfavorable entropy term.
And that's the reason why
we get a negative value
for delta G naught at this temperature.
Let's compare the
calculation that we just did
at a temperature of 100,
which gave us a negative
value for delta G naught,
to a similar calculation,
except this time we have
a much higher temperature.
This time it's 2000.
But notice how the
values for delta H naught
and delta S naught are the same as before.
The reason why we can use the same values
at a different temperature
is because delta H and delta S naught
don't change much with temperature.
However, delta G naught does
change a lot with temperature.
Because at this higher
temperature, when we do the math,
we see that now we get delta
G naught is equal to +100.
So at this higher temperature,
even though the enthalpy
term is favorable,
now the unfavorable entropy term
outweighs the favorable enthalpy term
and gives us a positive
value for delta G naught.
Therefore, at a relatively
lower temperature,
delta G naught is negative.
However, at a higher temperature,
delta G naught is positive.
So when delta H naught is
negative, that's favorable,
but when delta S naught is
negative, that's not favorable.
And we just saw from the calculations
that delta G naught will be
negative at low temperatures.
So let's write that in here in our chart.
So far we've been talking
about delta G naught
relative to a chemical process.
However, delta G naught also
applies to a physical process.
In this case
we're looking at liquid water
turning into solid water.
So this is the process of freezing.
The process of freezing gives off energy.
So this process is exothermic,
and delta H naught will be negative.
Going from a liquid to a solid
is a decrease in entropy,
therefore, delta S naught is negative.
For this combination of signs,
delta G naught is negative
only at relatively low temperatures.
Therefore, the forward process of freezing
is thermodynamically
favorable at low temperatures.
And this matches with what
we already know about water,
water freezes at a
relatively low temperature.
Finally, let's look at our
fourth combination of signs,
and that's when both delta H naught
and delta S naught are positive.
So let's say delta H
naught is equal to +100,
delta S naught is equal able to +0.1,
and first we'll look at the
lower temperature of 100.
Doing the math, we get positive 100 - 10,
which gives us a positive
value for delta G naught.
And if we do the calculation
at a higher temperature of 2000,
notice that delta H naught is still +100
and delta S not is still +0.1.
This time we get -100 for delta G naught.
Notice how for this example
at the higher temperature,
the entropy term is unfavorable
for giving a negative
value for delta G naught.
However, the entropy term is favorable.
A positive value for delta S naught
gives a positive value
for the entropy term.
And since we are subtracting it,
the entropy term outweighs
the enthalpy term,
giving a negative value
for delta G naught.
However, for the first example
at the lower temperature,
since the temperature is lower,
the entropy term is a smaller value,
and is unable to overcome the
unfavorable enthalpy term.
And that's the reason why delta G naught
ends up being positive
at the lower temperature.
So for this combination of signs,
delta G naught is negative
at higher temperatures.
So for our fourth combination,
when delta H naught is positive,
that is unfavorable.
However, when delta S naught
is positive, that is favorable.
And we just saw that delta
G naught is less than zero
at high temperatures.
So I'll go ahead and write
in on our table here,
'at high temperatures.'
As an example of this,
let's consider solid water
turning into liquid water.
So the forward process is
the process of melting.
It takes energy
to disrupt the intermolecular
forces of the solid,
therefore, heat is on the reactant side
and delta H naught is positive.
Melting is an endothermic process.
Going from a solid to a liquid
is an increase in entropy.
Therefore, delta S naught is positive.
And when both signs are positive,
our calculations showed us
that delta G naught is less
than zero at high temperatures.
Therefore, the forward process of melting
is thermodynamically favorable
at relatively high temperatures.
And this matches what we
already know from experience.
At relatively low temperatures
ice does not melt.
However, at relatively high
temperatures ice does melt.
Now that we have our chart filled out,
let's summarize what we've learned
about these four possible combinations.
When delta H naught and delta
S naught are both favorable,
the forward process is
thermodynamically favorable
at all temperatures.
When delta H naught and delta
S naught are both unfavorable,
the forward process is
thermodynamically favorable
at no temperatures,
or you could say the forward process
is thermodynamically
unfavorable at all temperatures.
When delta H naught is favorable
and delta S naught is unfavorable,
the forward process is only
thermodynamically favorable
at low temperatures.
And finally, if delta H
naught is unfavorable,
but delta S naught is favorable,
the forward process is
thermodynamically favorable
only at high temperatures.